Ha ha ha kakimora revenge. Bye. Bye. Hey guys
It's time to get frosty what do you think would happen if we tried putting a coconut in liquid nitrogen?
Would it crack open? For today's experiment
I jumped down to the comments
And I pulled this one out from Tommy Linden who says "could you please try a coconut in liquid nitrogen to see if it cracks?"
Open that's an interesting request there tommy so today we're doing this experiment for you now to make this experiment possible today
I ran down to the grocery store this morning and picked up four coconuts
I'm also bringing back this monster filled with 35 liters of liquid nitrogen as well as this styrofoam crate
I'm using styrofoam because it has more insulating properties than some of the containers
I've used in the past and the hope is I'll be able to save more liquid nitrogen by using styrofoam rather than metal dish
[Music]
So here we are guys. I've literally just emptied the rest of my dewar into the styrofoam container
And this thing is full of a lot of nitrogen in fact. I'm completely out now
I may have to make some more this thing is almost full to the top
We better not spill it because things get awfully cold if we did, but this is exactly the kind of setup
I wanted because I want to be able to submerge these coconuts completely
I want them to freeze as quickly as possible. No shallow containers. We're going all in I just need to grab pair of tongs
Are these things even strong enough to pick up a coconut ?
That could work. This is pretty sketchy, but I think it's going to work. Alright, coconut number one, here we go
And we're going all in
Bubble bubble bubble this thing wants to float look at that the coconut is floating
I take it back, no actually it is kind of floating
That's like half and half, half's floating and half's not
You can definitely tell where the coconut is because there's like isolated boiling
All this is pretty calm
And then this is boiling right over here which means that's where our coconut  that got little pieces of coconut husk floating around
Alright, we've been in for about 15 seconds and pull it out and take a look
Oop if I can get it out
There we go. This thing is slippery these aren't the best tongs
We got some cracking there. That's cool
Looking that's getting a little crispy I
Can still hear the water shaking around the inside?
I'm kind of tempted to freeze this thing until the water doesn't shake anymore
Like can we freeze it solid?
Just for the sake of time. I'm going to go ahead and throw in all four coconuts at once
What do you think about that but before we do let's just check on coconut number one?
Looking pretty good. That's cold. Here we go,  check that little guy out
Listening listen to the crack
The water inside is still liquid
You can see it cracking on the outside of the shell here. I'm just curious to know at this point
if I capped it with a hammer
Apparently not much all right. Let's go back in
along with all of his little buddies ha ha ha ha kakimura revenge
bye-bye
Whoo doggy wait. I want to play, too.
Oh gosh, that's a lot of lookin I think I
I got the lid on just to prevent the nitrogen from escaping too rapidly now
Let's just go ahead and let that sit for about 10 minutes
And then come back and craft our footnotes with a hammer
All right guys it is 15 minutes later check her out the edges here the gaps of the styrofoam look at it's getting all
Frosty all this stuff is like shooting out like spikes. It's very very cool like mini icicles do that with that all around the gap
Cool
Hopefully that's been able to salvage a little bit of nitrogen, and I'm seeing we've only dropped about 2 inches in volume
Which is very very good considering you're not a mass we head in there now the question is have these
Coconuts frozen all the way through let's do the shake test
If I can even get these things out there we go
Coconut on number 1. Oh wow my gloves are freezing shaking it
well
I don't hear any of the water shaking around, so
Potentially this thing now is completely frozen. I'm going to give it a little drop test three, two, one
Three , two , one
Maybe a little bit harder a forceful drop.There we go look at that
Look at that. Oh my gosh. You know what?
What?
The shell just came right off and that is all the meat
Oh boy, oh, wow wow wow look at that?
There's our coconut water frozen completely solid here's our coconut meat
I wonder if we can get the rest of this thing out look at that it just all falls out
Whoa
There's our shell. There's our coconut meat. There's our coconut water
That's crazy. I got to put that in the glass before it thaws
You know what's really cool about this is this thing just fell right out of the shell
I have never got the meat out of a coconut as cleanly as that that is absolutely perfect
There's nothing left in there no scraping no risking cutting off your fingers with the blade of a knife
No endless prying it just like cracked and fell right out
Easiest coconut de meating ever. Is
de meating even a word?
Now I do have to say this is quite cold to hang on to but if I keep moving it, it doesn't freeze my fingers
Grab it smack it rotate smack it rotate smack it what that's doing is. It's breaking up everything on the inside just
Just like that look at how that shatters. This is a coconut, and it just shattered
into a bajillion pieces
Me that the shell just falls right away
Now my hands getting really cold okay, take these pieces of coconut water there now like glass
Put them in a cup that'll cool you down in the hot summer sun
Look at that
It looks like a ball of ice
pure coconut water
That's a little gem. I'm hanging on to
Goes right in there oop these pieces of the meat here are extremely hard and extremely brittle
That's satisfying. Okay next
No skinny cracks yet
Hulk Smash
That's the way to get it done right there look at that. Oh
Wouldn't it be cool if we get the whole coconut out in one piece.
Oh look at that
What?
That's the inside of the coconut it's completely intact no cracks
But that's the meat and on the inside of the meat is the coconut water
Look at all the veins in it. It almost looks like some kind of organ like it seriously does look organic
That's so cool. Eel heart. This is kind of mind-blowing guys
this is what the inside of your coconut looks like if you remove the shell it's completely intact unscratched and
Still full of coconut water. I'm going to let this file out because I'm quite proud of that. I think we can do it again
Probably not
All right last one. No cracks to begin with transfer it to the chopping block
You can see how brittle that shell is just a few taps from a hammer and starts cracking all over
and then
Just pops right off. I wasn't quite as lucky with this one
You can see the meat did crack we turn this upside down the rest of it falls out. It's freezing. My hand like crazy
Here we go transfer our coconut water in there
Look at that
It's like a coconut puzzle 3D puzzle. Good luck trying to put that back together so guys that's pretty cool
And I have to admit. I never really know what to expect. We're going to try something like this and the results are always
Mind-blowing we start off just trying to see what would happen if you put a coconut and liquid nitrogen
Would it actually get cold enough that it would crack but in four different cases?
We didn't see any of our coconut shells begin to crack
But we did notice that the shells were brittle enough if we give them a little tap with a hammer or drop them hard enough
Under something like a concrete surface they would crack enough to expose the meat and the water on the inside
We also notice this only works as well as it does if you shake the coconut
And you can't hear the water sloshing around
It needs to be frozen completely solid and what was completely mind-blowing for me
It was coconut number three because we removed the shelf and kept the inner parts completely intact
I don't know about you, but I have never actually seen the inside of a coconut in whole and intact like this before
It's very well could be a first very cool
I'm going to let this thing thaw and when it's completely warmed back up to room temperature
The whole thing will be edible outside and in the heart of the coconut
Getting this stuff out of the shells really is most of the work
But as long as they got a little bit of liquid nitrogen and a hammer no sweat
And a big thanks to Tommy Linden for suggesting this experiment today, you can go check your Youtube inbox
Tommy I'm sending you 25 bucks
So there you have a guy's liquid nitrogen versus coconut very cool experiment and very glad that you were here to join me for it
Thanks for hopping into this video. I'll be looking for you the next one. Talk to you then
Stuff is pretty dang expensive, so I'm saving it
Sweet now we have more for another day
Follow me on Instagram @billy.adamo